stupid small phone stupid small buttons
stupid big fingers Pete why our
developers trying to torture me well
they're not really trying to torture you
well it really seems like it when the
buttons are so small that they barely
take up a pixel on the screen yeah it's
true
tap targets or anything that a user
might touch tap click or try and do
input on need to be big enough and easy
to hit and spaced so that you're not
gonna accidentally hit two at the same
time with the mouse users can be
perfectly accurate our fingers on the
other hand and sorry about that pun it
was bad but our fingers are about 10
millimetres wide or half an inch which
works out to be about 40 CSS pixels okay
so button should be at least 40 by 40
pixels well instead of doing 40 by 40
you should make them 48 pixels wide by
48 pixels tall that makes sure that
there's enough room between the elements
for those of us who have fat fingers and
fat thumbs yeah it's okay to make some
tap targets a little bit smaller but
make sure there's at least 40 pixels of
room between any of your tap targets to
make sure that users don't hit two
buttons or two elements at the same time
or miss it completely